hi um my name is caste and I'm from
Texas I was wondering since you all have
pretty distinct characters um if you
could each have like if your characters
could have a theme song what would it be
and why
oh by mice's be like caroline's would be
I'm a Barbie girl in a Barbie world I
don't know I think I know Stephan's I
think it's when the man loves a woman
who is that Michael Bolton oh he write
that yeah maybe
okay whatever I think that's Stefan song
um I think Damon was the audition oh
yeah that's good son Wow
maybe some people ain't no good Nick
Cave people people just say no good what
the [ __ ] his name I saw that one that
one look it up Damon's would be eye of
the tiger and damn fancy Damon is Camaro
like going to the blood bank I'll pissed
off cuz Stefan will let him eat people
Matt yaki there do you want to trim in
you know what let's go back to the 80s
ac/dc
you shook me all night long I like oh
yeah but I think Matt has to have a love
life for that though no I'm good over
here
right that's genius
thank you very much sorry you had to ask
that lighten the mood down I did lighten
the mood why was the mood heavy what do
you mean hi Ian hi Paul hello hi we're
here also I know I so um I just want to
ask you in um what was your inspiration
for that sexy look you make like at the
time and if you can do it for us right
now please just be sexy it's a very good
question I that look is like a million
different things mainly conservation
mainly consequence debate well when I
concede this character I wanted him to
sort of be like like Mick Jagger meets
Brando by way of somebody like Mick
Jagger or somebody somebody like Cary
Grant kind of thing and so that look is
either did I forget my keys I like to
call my underwear clean I like to call
it's like a million different things you
know what it is in come on it's the
sandstorm there's a sandstorm imagine a
sandstorm just on the wind blowing sand
that's what it is come on we all do it's
the actor trick pretend you're in a
sandstorm Clint Eastwood okay by the way
we all came up with that season one and
it's a bunch of [ __ ] it's not a
sandstorm it's just wind wind I think
it's a sans sans Tora
it's amazing wind we're just like
nearsighted thank you for the question
thank you great but it is a lot of funny
little the synapse firings in my brain
is the most random [ __ ] you can imagine
hi hi my name is Kristen I'm from
Columbus Ohio where I'm a CEO so like I
said I'm a zookeeper there so thank you
Ian for ISF and all the conservation
stuff you do
well thanks um my question is for the
rest of you guys what do you plan on
doing now that the show is done is there
projects that you're collecting
unemployment projects that you want to
dedicate your time to I'm not gonna
answer this question yeah well
thankfully everybody remains employed
until we wrap in February let's just try
it we're we have till we have till
February we have the work our asses off
um until then so one of the things
that's been nice about the way we've
been talking about this is you know
we've all been together for so long and
the idea that this last season is about
bringing it all home we're back in
Mystic Falls the the episode titles are
all lines of dialogue from the first
season of the show where we're
revisiting relationships and and ideas
and and and themes that we that we even
in events you know decade dances that we
did in the early seasons and so I think
we're gonna work together to bring
everything we have to this last season
and knowing that it's hard out there
it's tough world out there I think
everyone's really we've been doing this
for so long now and we've learned so
much and our passions and our skill sets
have been altering you know directing
producing all of us are pretty much
going you know Katerina Graham it's like
writing songs at five in the morning and
I mean Vampire Diaries is like the
ultimate boot camp I mean we all have
worked very very hard and and and it's
like shooting a film every eight days
yeah epic film Paul you're out there
like selling shows my wife and I just
started a production company we're doing
the same thing like it's all very
yes boot camp we learned a lot thank you
Kevin Thank You Julie thank you guys
we've also had these two loving
individuals kind of harboring us like
the real world what is that again I
don't understand like I read the news
and stuff but I've been kind of in a
comfort zone yeah getting by these two
lovely people so stepping out of the
real world and some big-boy shoes in
first big surprise I will so one more
question
hi I'm Zoe and I'm from New Zealand
hello hi um I'm the last question so I
just want to ask if you could play
another character regardless of gender
who would it be and why in the show yeah
you mean in life or you mean in the show
in the show I play Caroline just cuz
she's so bubbly I need some positivity
in my life Rebecca
I feel like I just couldn't play anyone
but Carol I think I part of me just is
Caroline at the end of the day yes yes
so Martha Stewart I play a lot let's see
what it was like to kiss me see if
everyone's lying you know see you
everyone like Elijah because he's got
those wonderful suits and he looks so
damn good all the time he's got that
accent yeah yeah that accents I was laws
I was hanging out in New Zealand look at
that we brought it home full circle yeah
I can't imagine playing anyone but
Bonnie honestly I just love myself too
much I just shut up all
the moment it's good that's true the
great thing about playing some of these
characters though you ever you know it's
we Julie's kind of right like it's weird
out there we're in a really weird place
in the world people are angry about a
lot of [ __ ] and I don't know if it's
like all the pesticides or all the crazy
thanks for watching but like when
someone cuts you off if someone does
send me to me in traffic or something or
I'm in a bad mood I just go to work I
can just put it into the work and it's
all Jeff thanks bro well what's great
about not only have we become a family
over the past seven years but these
characters I think for me personally I
feel like Caroline feels like a sense of
home in itself going to work to play her
just feels like I'm at home and so it's
sad to leave all of these great people
but to also say goodbye to these
characters that you've been a part of
and that have eventually become a part
of you and when life does imitate art at
some points it's yeah it's are we all
gonna lose our minds hi me Mike what's
gonna happen to your hair I've got no
change are you handling Shay really
concerned yeah
know what to do your girl is that gonna
happen I don't have to wake up at 3:00
in the morning to do it anymore
know what to do all right guys that is
all of my time we have guys we thank you
thank you so so much love
thank you thank you thank you thank you
you